I'm Tony Hawk and two of my favorite
movies are The Naked Gun and The Spy Who
Loved me
you knew it was James Bond so he's gonna
live but the first thing the movie is
the ski chase in which he's being shot
out he's doing all these you know ski
stunts and then turns his pole into a
gun and then ends up skiing off a cliff
and skydiving like that was all about me
I love that stuff you know the whole
idea that there was gadgets and it was
stunts and literally death-defying it's
not like I was aspiring to do that but I
wanted to do something like that I just
always thought it was cool that my dad
would take me to movies that were a
little bit edgy for my age you know like
I wouldn't saw James Bond movies when I
was 10 years old my dad made it a point
to take me to the movies like that was
that was our outing this is about the
time I started skating so I think that
maybe it was his way of keeping me out
of the skate park for a couple hours and
actually spending time with me first
time I ever had a skateboard I was about
nine years old my brother was skating in
the alleyway and I picked up one of his
used decks and I just started trying it
but I remember it vividly because I
stood on it and I went down the alley
and I couldn't figure out how to turn
and I was yelling back at him how do I
turn out of my turn and I ran to the
fence yeah my first experience on a
skateboard was definitely I'm gonna get
gun movie the scene where norburg gets
shot touches his hand on the furnace
hits the wall with the wet paint it gets
caught in a bear trap like oh that's
just such a brilliant idea you just
can't take ourselves that seriously and
skateboarding is just a way to stay
immature the rest of your life that's
like a Naked Gun is it's a way to make
immature movies the kind of movies I
like to share with my kids from my youth
our movies like Naked Gun in airplanes
one man in this force will rest for one
minute until he's behind bars now let's
grab a bite to eat yeah very much the
way my family talked to each other you
know there was a lot of sarcasm there's
a lot of dry humor and you better be
witty if you're gonna you know if you're
gonna be noticed bingo to this day it's
so funny and I love sharing that with my
kids
the greatest gift my dad gave me was was
time it was spending time with me and
and and that's what I took with me does
a parent it's more about that you really
connect with your kids and I really want
to be there for them and to
that time with them the way that my dad
did when I took my kids to see a movie
especially one that might be a little
edgy for their age it definitely gives
me flashbacks of going to the movies
with my dad
it felt I don't know like kind of
naughty like we were breaking the rules
like maybe it's not something my mom
would appreciate so much and I feel the
same way for them but they're like I
don't think mom would really be
struggling you're fine don't worry about
work we're good I'm Tony Hawk and I love
movies